before I get started I kind of just want
to preface everything with although this
is semi purpose-built for underwriting
commercial lending for small to
mid-sized businesses a lot of the
concepts are general enough in
applicability to where maybe you could
extend it for a different type of credit
risk evaluation and really it's just a
story about how a bunch of really great
tools come together to create a system
that you know if done a different way
could have been a lot more complex and a
lot less intuitive so with that I will
get started so I work for a company
called c2fo and I'm telling you about
c2fo because it plays into the
understanding of how all of this works
but c2fo stands for collaborative cash
flow optimization try to say that ten
times fast good luck but we exist
because of this problem down here so
globally there's about thirty eight
trillion dollars locked up and accounts
payable and accounts receivable that's
to say that if you're a company like
Amazon you have hundreds of thousands of
suppliers in your supply chain right and
at a given point in time if I'm one of
those suppliers maybe Amazon owes me 10
million dollars for some t-shirts
typical terms of payment are 30 60 or 90
days for those types of goods and maybe
I want to as the supplier I want to
start a new factory or hire some new
workers historically they would have had
to go through a bank or what's known as
a factor and they would take a huge
discount on the nose to to get paid
early for those for those invoices that
are due to them but maybe that same day
amazon sitting on like 15 billion cash
and they're simply looking to make a six
percent rate of return what c2fo does is
facilitates a market where we can match
up the bars and suppliers where a buyer
who has one desired rate of return and
then a supplier who's bidding in terms
of APR a discount you know in terms of
what they're willing to forego to get
paid early we just match the two up in
the market and it's win-win because
buyer gets what they want and supplier
gets what they
the lowest cost of capital available to
them so in a given day we have you know
maybe a couple billion flowing through
our markets and this is all possible
because we have hooks that go into the
buyers ERP systems and every night we
get all of their invoices and we've been
doing this for several years so that's
kind of c2fo in a nutshell and it's cool
when you think about the trickle-down
effect that that has when suppliers have
access to that capital that they would
have otherwise had to wait for and
there's a 38 trillion dollar problem out
there the trickle-down effects for the
global economy are pretty profound so
it's at school anyway WFC this is what
we're talking about today the water for
commerce fund so when there is a buyer
that is not part of the c2fo network yet
and you know that supplier has accounts
receivable outstanding with them we want
to be able to help them too but we can't
do so through c2fo proper so we created
this investment fund which is also a
lending platform that will address those
those outstanding buyers as well so
basically we've developed a systematic
underwriting process a systematic
prospecting and underwriting process
that uses the c2fo data and like I said
over five years of daily invoices and
adjustments so think about that for a
second daily when you compare that to
what a bank might ask you for is a small
business owner a couple of static not
audited financial statements which one
do you think is more telling of you know
that businesses cash flow the daily
information that we've observed over
several years or a static unaudited
statement you be the judge and we have
this information on over 200,000
suppliers currently and growing as an
investor we're talking about like 40 day
duration 6.25 percent return you know
kind of an unheard-of return profile
there so a very attractive opportunity
for investors to if all of that was
clear as mud I drew a picture so this is
kind of
c2fo proper over here where this
supplier for example let's just say the
b1 in this example is Amazon okay and
they're on the sea to FL platform but
this is target and this is home depot oh
and this is you know nordstrom er
actually Nordstrom's one of our buyers
to but Dillard's ok so maybe thirty
percent of their accounts receivable are
coming from target up here and they want
to get funded that's where WFC comes in
they would upload those invoices after
we you know how to conversation with
them and systematically into Road them
and you know we'll get through the rest
but why are we doing this you guys have
probably heard of a dozen you know
commercial lenders that seems like
they're popping up every day to do the
same thing why even bother hopefully by
the end of this presentation you guys
will understand you know why we why we
decided to go this route based on the
information that we have because at the
end of the day all risk is not created
equal we do believe we have a serious
competitive advantage based on the
volume of data that we have in the type
of data that we have we also think we
can do it in a very transparent way that
doesn't rate gouge you might recall that
some other big lenders had some very
negative publicity lately for for rate
gouging some of their borrowers in a
very you know misleading way for
investors I mentioned it before it's
it's a very very you know good
opportunity we haven't had a single
default in you know since the fun
started and that's that's something to
be proud of but all of this is possible
at the end of the day because we have
great tools this may remind you of you
know the the sticker table out there
it's an amalgamation of different
open-source libraries that many of you
are probably familiar with PI pandas
syfy XG boost matplotlib Luigi numpy
task spacey you can see the rest so high
level risk management overview we're
going to be breaking down you know these
blue boxes represent kind of process
the red boxes represent different types
of risk that will be addressing and then
the green boxes up top address specific
components of that risk that we're
effectively mitigating so let's get
started first thing concentration risk
simply put all things all things equal
if you have two suppliers and one of
them is only invoicing to buyers and the
other one is invoicing ten buyers what
does that tell you that tells you that
one is a lot more diverse and you know
the likelihood if one of those buyers
says we don't want your goods anymore
you know then that that takes down their
accounts receivable by 50% overnight
right you'd rather have a more
diversified supplier that's doing
business with multiple buyers so just to
make that a little bit more clear you
can see a two bar scenario here a 3 bar
scenario here and this this supplier has
I can't count that maybe eight or nine
different buyers and this is easy stuff
in pandas right just a little little
pivot table little group buy whatever
you want then a stacked area plot
obviously using latest and greatest
color maps this is easy stuff and you
know we can calculate those percentages
over time and score somebody more
favorably if they have more diversity
there's also this notion of junk so
who's familiar with you know Moody's
bond ratings for example right okay so
if a particular buyer like let's pick on
payless shoes for example do you think
paila if a supplier was doing business
with payless shoes and then another
supplier is doing business with costco
who would you rather who would you
rather lend to the supplier that's bar
up that's doing business with costco
because the likelihood of costco going
out of business tomorrow and not you
know fulfilling their debt obligations
is pretty low so we can factor in junk
and that's to say that a higher
percentage of their accounts receivable
coming from a buyer that we deemed junk
effectively penalizes them so that kind
of covers concentration risk now we'll
talk mostly about default risk it's
obviously the the biggest area that that
we're thinking about
and default risk basically translates to
the what's the likelihood that this
supplier that your lightning too is not
going to be able to pay back pay you
back and fulfill their obligation so one
way that we can mitigate this risk is by
forecasting their accounts receivable so
if I'm engaging in a 40-day lending
agreement with the supplier wouldn't it
be nice to be able to forecast down to a
very small margin of error how much
accounts receivable that particular
supplier is going to have coming in the
door yes yes it would so there are quite
a few different forecasting libraries
out there to do this sort of thing you
know who here uses are for forecasting
okay couple who uses Python for
forecasting okay about about the same r
has a lot of libraries that have been
quote unquote battle-tested that have
been around for quite some time and
they're quite fantastic but you know
caveat here is that we're also
evaluating new tools like pie flux and I
know that stats models is also
implementing some of these models and
future releases as well but things like
your autoregressive integrated moving
average you know whole winters
exponential smoothing Beijing structural
time series which is this more recent
methodology than some of these others
and then you know your good old good old
fashioned OLS or polynomial regression
and this is what it looks like so this
is a supplier that has a very very
evident seasonal pattern here and you
can see the red is there 90 day forecast
90 days is that the maximum duration
that we would be willing to engage in a
lending agreement with a supplier so
that's what we're concerned with
forecasting out we require at least five
quarters right because we're going to go
ahead and fit our model on an entire
years worth of data and then we want to
back test it on the last quarter so five
five quarters make sense there and then
the image on your right shows what our
forecast would have actually been 90
days ago versus the actuals so you see
that we're getting quite close here
without showing you you know the actual
maven rmse here's an
other example of a supplier these guys
have an invoicing pattern that's like a
metronome very predictable cash coming
in in cash going out I didn't mention
this subplot down here this is actually
a ratio of their adjustments to invoices
so what I'm talking about invoices think
about a positive inflow and an
adjustment a negative outflow so when
when that goes out of whack when they
have some unprecedented outflows of cash
that should be concerning that should
raise some race um you know raise some
alarms but up here you can see that they
have a very very predictable adjustment
accounts receivable pattern at least
over the history that we've observed and
there are a couple other things going on
in this visualization that that I'll
touch on a little bit but the two things
that we really look at to evaluate this
best model strategy are the MAPE the the
mean absolute percentage error and the
rmse the rude mean squared error for the
backtest and we run through each one of
those models that I mentioned before
whether it's you know simple regression
polynomial regression Beijing structural
time series we do that every one of
those models with different parameter
configurations on a nightly basis for
200,000 suppliers so we're literally
running millions of models every single
evening so that we can have the best
forecast possible every single day and
you know just in this plot here you can
see various annotations some subplot
action all these things made possible
because of Matt plot libs you know high
high level of customization you know
sometimes you can there are clean like
more straightforward ap is out there but
for just extensibility you can do some
pretty great stuff in matplotlib if
you're looking for a static image so
let's move on a little bit to
seasonality so if a supplier is is
highly seasonal so let's say they go
through like a big hill and then that
they have a serious valley if you were
about to lend to them for 40 days or
something like that you want to
lend to them when they're about to go up
that hill as opposed to when they're
about to go down that Valley so we can
kind of understand seasonality a very
granular level by running a seasonal
decomposition which is available in
stats models basically this is the
original signal up here and we're
decoupling the seasonality component
from the trend component the trend
component is in the green here and then
you can see the seasonality component in
orange and then the residual is
everything that's left over that can't
be explained by by those two vectors so
very important to understand seasonality
as well now that we've kind of talked
about forecasting their accounts
receivable we can talk about predicting
AR discontinuation so I want to make a
very clear distinction between what I'm
calling AR discontinuation and
bankruptcy so bankruptcy you know
complete nuclear event they put their
hands up in the air and they can't
fulfill their debt obligations but AR
discontinuation from our perspective is
when they cease to invoice the buyers
that they were historically invoicing so
we can train a classifier to do that
what's the probability that they're
going to flatline in 45 days ok in order
to do that though we have to be
meticulous about how we're preparing our
data you guys have heard of data leakage
show of hands who's heard of that term
ok basically you do not want to be able
to observe that which would have not
been observable at the point that you
want to make the prediction so since we
want a 45-day jump on when somebody is
going to flatline in terms of their
accounts receivable we have to go back
45 we have to first label all of our
suppliers right did they flat line or
did they not flat line for this period
of time and then we want to truncate
that data 45 days before that and then
start engineering features off of that
truncated data set because you know if
you didn't do that that you wouldn't be
able to make those 45 those predictions
45 days out the right way so then we can
start engineering features so just a
little suggestion i found this method of
feature engineering for this type of
problem to be very effective i usually
like to engineer
is based on you know aggregate stats
over their entire history then I might
take some type of like windowed history
like maybe the last 13 weeks or
something and engineer the same features
off of off of that period and then maybe
you know some additional features just
on that on that last observable day so
engineering different features with diff
over different time windows has proven
effective for for us so features
engineer data truncated check check
let's keep going so we use Sai kit for
some of the additional preparation you
know when we're talking about encoding
categoricals creating polynomial
features scaling reducing dimensionality
and all that fun stuff and then we have
a pipeline of models that run to
determine the best model but lo and
behold a lot of times gradient boosted
trees end up winning out which you need
to be very careful that you're not over
fitting for because it's very easy to do
that but the the X sike it has an API
for XG boost so you know if you're
creating a pipeline inside kid and
you're very familiar with psych its API
and you don't want to you know use the
XG boost one there's actually a way to
instantiate a gradient boosted tree in
the side kid fashion which is which is
nice for a maintainable pipeline and
then for hyper parameter tuning we're
currently using the hyper off library I
should note though that hyper opt seems
like it has not been actively developed
for a little while and so you know you
have to pay attention to those kind of
things but we're currently evaluating
experiment which does Beijing ops
optimization as well at the end of the
day we're concerned about recall so I
don't want to beat this point into the
ground you know the difference between
precision and recall type 1 type 2
errors here too much but basically we it
costs us a lot if we get this
classification wrong if somebody ends up
flatlining and ceasing to invoice those
buyers and not being able to fulfill
their debt obligation guess what that's
a default in the portfolio guess what
that
it's a lot of uncertainty with her
investors that creates all sorts of
problems so we're very very concerned
about optimizing for recall here and of
course not overfitting so we talked
about default discontinuation or AR
discontinuation but now let's talk about
bankruptcy so bankruptcy can happen for
a lot of different reasons maybe you
know the executive team overnight had a
big argument or something maybe there
was some type of macroeconomic condition
that came about that was damaging to
that particular business maybe there was
policy change you know there could be a
host of different things but based on
c2fo s data advantage we would have no
clear competitive advantage over any
other you know bank or commercial lender
for predicting those types of things
with with our data so we want to use our
data in conjunction with some of some
third-party data to do that but that's
not the easiest thing to do who's
familiar with Pacers the Pacers database
it's like a global database with
bankruptcy information has a really
awful website and a really terrible ABI
but anyway it's the only place that you
can go for bankruptcy data really that's
that's like a V source so once we pull
down all this data from Pacers you know
on a nightly basis we need to figure out
okay is Bob's plumbing the same as Bob's
plumbing LLC you know whatever we called
them in our database so we have to
figure out you know who's who matches up
and then we need to the same way I was
talking about before truncate the data
and engineer some features and rich it
with macro data and then you have to
address a class and balance problem too
right because think about the proportion
of businesses that go out of business
versus stay in business so there's an
imbalance there and then we need to
train some models but I want to talk
about this matching process because we
learned a lot in doing it and I think
what we did was was pretty novel and
pretty applicable for others too
obviously we want to convert to
lowercase remove special characters all
that super obvious stuff
first then I want to do the easy stuff
first when I start talking about string
matching and sound exes that stuff is
harder okay if I have a tax ID on both
sides of the fence you better believe
I'm going to use that first if I have a
phone number on both sides of the fence
i'm going to use that first i'm going to
do the easy stuff before the hard stuff
reduce the load on you know the batch
processing that I have to do then what I
do to make my feature space or my search
space a little bit smaller is use sound
X's right we can we can take a term
convert it to a sound X and then only
run string matching on the sound exes
that are in the ballpark so that you
know helps the runtime this stuff
because it's expensive to do some of
these things when you start talking
about levenshtein distance you're a
winkler distance Jaccard distance these
are all expensive processes when you
need to do them for over two hundred
thousand suppliers on a nightly basis
along with all the other modeling that I
talked about so using using the sound
X's helps reduce that that's search
space a little bit and then what we do
last is calculate the Geo distance
that's to say that you know maybe maybe
a company is headquartered in wilmington
delaware a lot of companies are
incorporated there because they have
lacks tax laws and some other reasons
but in any case if we see that the
distance between 11 supplier and then
the the bankrupt company that we saw is
0 then that increases our confidence
that it's the same exact location even
if the the string matching score was a
little bit off so we can just do some
you know basic have a signed distance to
to ensure that or to have like a
multiplicative effect on the score when
it's a closer and just just a pro tip
here if you're rolling your own like
have a sine function for some reason
because you can stack overflow that and
find 10 different implementations but
when you're doing this sort of thing if
you're compelled to roll your own I
would strongly suggest trying to siphon
eyes or wrap it and you know numba jit
decorator so that you can stand to
benefit from you know either that just
in time or static compilation
because rolling your own and pure python
won't be the fastest i can guarantee
that much so this is what it ends up
looking like when we might have fresh
gourmet concepts inc over here and then
fresh gourmet concepts over here you can
see that some of the string matching
comes back really high but then you can
see here that the geo distance was zero
so they have a greater than perfect
score here at 4.01 for another example
network salon services versus or network
salon services LLC rather versus network
salon services you can see that their
string matching score was not perfect
either but there were only 1.5 mile
miles away maybe that was like the store
owner who lived you know around the
corner or something like that and used
her personal address because it's an LLC
sort of thing so you get the point but
that was how we matched up you know what
we saw in the Pacers database with what
we had in our database just a couple fun
facts about bankruptcy since I was
looking at that data anyway when you
look at it from two thousand nine to
2016 you can see that it's you know
going down a little bit generally
speaking and you know makes sense
because of the economic crisis but a lot
of conventional wisdom starts bubbling
up when you see things like hotels and
motels or let's see eating places as
some of the most common si si codes for
for going out of business and again you
know we got to use a good color map
everybody that works on my team knows
that I'm a real stickler for for
visualizations this isn't my favorite
color map on this heat map but you know
it was hard to get this to really
highlight the interesting part of it so
on the x-axis here you have employee
count and on the y-axis you have the
company sales so kind of makes sense
right you see up here that the smaller
companies with fewer employees less
sales tend to go out of business a lot
more often that's not to say that some
of the big boys never do but you know
keep this sort of thing in mind if
you're thinking about that's why
startups are risky right because it's
hard but these these middle areas
tend to go out a lot less often so we've
covered default risk and i also want to
talk about fraud risk whenever you're
engaging in a lending agreement with
somebody it's like a hinge it's like a
handshake you have to evaluate that that
borrowers character on some dimension as
well so we do that a couple different
ways and this is where natural language
processing comes into play so if one of
our customer service reps is on the
phone with one of these suppliers that
we've prospected we record all the
conversations we you know we use
Watson's NOP API to do the to do the
transcriptions and then we do some of
the text mining on our side with with
the Spacey library which is very nice
very fast but here you can see like a
little excerpt of of text that was that
trip to red flag because one of these
words was was said and we look for words
like dead leverage bankruptcy lien
payroll the types of things that you
would not want to hear if you're
thinking about engaging in a lending
agreement with somebody alcohol roll
over credit Cayman Islands you know big
big red flags so it's just not possible
or practical for a human to sit there
and do all this stuff so that's where
you know we needed to we create a system
for all of this another way that we kind
of assess character risk or fraud risk
is by analyzing invoice congruence so I
mentioned before that c2fo gets millions
of invoices every single evening from
all of our buyers right when when a
supplier qualifies for a loan we ask
them to upload their invoices they're
there in network invoices and they're
out of network invoices so if if in our
database you know we saw an invoice from
Nordstrom two weeks ago for 450 k and
then they send us an invoice from
Nordstrom for you know 600 k okay we
have a way of calling their bluff
because we have the source of truth from
the buyer so it's just another way to
ensure that you know they're a
trustworthy character I'm not going to
go into this this is pretty
straightforward math anyway but the
basic idea is just to compare
what they send us not only in terms of
you know the cumulative amount or the
number of invoices but we ultimately
arrive at what we call our congruence
score which which tells us how well does
what they they sent us match up with
what the buyers sent us now that we've
covered concentration risk default risk
fraud risk now we're kind of into the
portfolio management side of things okay
we've decided that this supplier is not
a nefarious character ok they're not a
default risk okay they have plenty of
diversification great let's go ahead and
engage in lending agreement with them
but the question is is well right before
we get to that point I should have
actually put this slide first but just
like each one of us have a credit score
that is unique to us our overall opinion
using an amalgamation of all the models
that I just mentioned is kind of
encapsulated in this WFC score so that's
what that's what this blue distribution
down here is which is which is roughly
normal now these read this read
distribution were suppliers that I
mentioned before that you needed to have
at least five quarters worth of data for
us to make a forecast but when you don't
we still want to be able to score those
suppliers up so classic machine learning
exercise right we have this population
that we have all of these observable
features for and we have their their
known labels or in this case it's a
score so continuous value so let's go
ahead and train some sort of regression
model to predict what their WFC score
would have been so that we have total
coverage for our prospect pool or you
know population that might borrow using
that WFC score and using all of the
information that that I mentioned before
we can decide on three things okay how
much should we lend to them what's the
credit limit what type of duration and
how do they fit into the overall
portfolio so to just give a very you
know straightforward example of how we
I decide on what their credit limit
might be let's say that they fall into
the top decile for their WFC score then
maybe we're willing to let to bar lend
them let's say fifty percent of what we
forecast that they have coming in the
door over the next 90 days okay maybe if
they fall into the second to top decile
then we're only willing to lend them up
to forty five percent of what we
forecasted that they have coming in the
door over the next 45 days so that's how
the forecast piece ties into
establishing a meaningful credit limit
and then in terms of the duration that
has to do with their invoices that they
that they uploaded that they're
borrowing against so basically the
higher decile translates to a greater
percentage of their cumulative forecasts
and rates are kind of a combination of
two things so this is where more
proprietary data comes into play through
the c2fo markets we've observed how
these suppliers have bid in terms of APR
a discount with all of their other
invoices with their further c2fo markets
so those those discounts that they're
bidding are usually good approximations
for what their cost of capital is so if
they have placed bids in the sea to FL
proper market before then we might be
able to establish you know some type of
rate based on that if not then you know
we get into kind of a convex
optimization problem where we're looking
at the overall portfolio what type of
risk they introduce what the duration is
etc and where we should set their rate
in order to achieve the desired rate of
return that we're looking for on the
fund so who should we continue lending
to once they're in the portfolio once
you fulfilled your debt obligation to us
that doesn't mean that the next time
around you know we're just going to go
ahead and give you the benefit of doubt
we monitor all sorts of different things
once you're in the portfolio things like
level shifts so that's when you have
some type of unprecedented spike
there's a really good our package that
Twitter developed called breakout
detection that was recently ported over
to python that we use to do some of that
we look for big changes so in the c2fo
markets again maybe one day somebody's
bidding at ten percent but the next day
they're up to 20 right that is a sign of
desperation like why are they suddenly
willing to you know for go so much more
something must have changed there so we
set off all these triggers on a nightly
basis to then kind of get in front of
any kind of default possibility we can
also monitor the WFC score that I
mentioned before overtime adjustments
buyer reserves which I don't really need
to get into too much but it ends up
looking something like this we have like
their diversity score moving average we
have that junk score that I mentioned
before the moving average the invoice
discontinuation probability a forecast
ratio and a backtest ratio which
basically speak to okay how favorable is
there a 90 day forecast and how well did
we predict their last 90 days based on
that back test and we can monitor these
things over time right very intuitive
and when there's a significant shift
then we know there's something wrong and
we need to get in front of it so high
level overview of risk management I know
I kind of talked about a lot of things
there but what it was all using those
those libraries that you guys are
probably already familiar with just
applying them you know in a problem
space that that was conducive for that
time behind the scenes all stars that I
did not mention things like anaconda for
for managing or Python in our
environments Luigi for pipeline task
orchestration and ask just for
paralyzing anything that that lends to
doing that much and you can see what our
Luigi dag or a directed acyclic graph
looks like over here so luigi in a
nutshell you know you can set up all of
these tasks
and you know you have dependencies and
when there's a failure in the pipeline
you don't necessarily need to restart
the entire pipeline you have everything
kind of serialized and some or C
realized or persisted in some way shape
or form so that you can restart the
pipeline at that point of failure and
then keep moving forward so that's
really cool because you can see that
this graph gets pretty complicated
pretty quickly but if you take a close
look at it all right everybody suit Sid
ok now let's do something to it let's
turn it upside down okay what does that
look like Cobra maybe a little bit yes
no I know it's kind of hard to say but
anyway I decided to nickname the project
project Cobra so all hail project Cobra
all right unfortunately I wanted to do a
demo but our VPN is down I know a real
pain but I did manage to get some
screenshots from an old presentation for
you so the only thing that I did not
talk about was the web application
framework that we used as anybody
familiar with spire who's heard of our
shiny okay a lot of you heard of our
shiny basically it's a Python port of
our that uses you know simple cherry pie
web server and jinja 24 templating and
you know a data scientist like me that
does not consider himself a front-end
developer can maintain it with with you
know relative ease so you know you can
put in an account number over here and
then pull up their information you can
adjust the length of the loan and then
that will recalculate their credit limit
on the fly you can look at their their
historical accounts receivable and
different levels of aggregation and you
can also throw some filters on there
then you can see the the back test plot
here on the back back test tab as well
as the seasonal decomposition and the
buyer plot and then the score plot that
I mentioned before and then the other
two tabs are really just rendering of
data frames as tables for additional
information like you know what si si was
this supplier or what's their annual
revenue or something like that and you
can also download all of this
information into one nice neat tear
sheet that then gets copied up to s3 for
bookkeeping purposes but all of this is
just terribly straightforward stuff when
you use that that spire library to do it
and it doesn't require you know any
hand-holding from our front-end
engineers that have their own kind of
products to maintain so you have to
think about these types of things when
you're when you're building you know a
system overall like this you know is
this code that I would want to maintain
you know two years from now am I just
creating a bunch of technical debt for
for somebody else you know you have to
be thoughtful of your of your peers in
that way so I always like to end my
talks with is so what you sat down you
you listen to me for the last you know
whatever it was 30 minutes but but
really so what about all this stuff so
the first thing that I want to mention
that actually Peter touched on earlier
today too is that objectivity gabes way
to innovation I think the way that he
stated it was that you know was it like
a new a new user or not knowing a
particular library as a feature not a
bug or something to that extent but but
really just the thought that coming in
with a fresh pair of eyes and not
necessarily just taking everything as
its told to you because maybe it doesn't
make a whole lot of sense the way that
it was being done before if you look at
the risk management systems for a lot of
the big banks they're probably a little
bit more involved than what we were
doing here but we're probably talking
about millions of lines of low-level
code that is just a hairball to maintain
right by approaching this problem
objectively we were able to simplify the
code base meet all of our requirements
in a very short amount of time and
create something that has been very
effective to date last year and a half
we haven't lost any money in the fund so
it's working quite well and you've
probably heard this one before to better
independent data beats more complex
algorithms can't drive that point home
and
you can sit there print hyper parameter
tuning you know all night long if you
want to but I would probably start
thinking about what kind of data you can
use to supplement your existing data and
what type of features you can engineer
that you weren't engineering before and
that's going to usually pay off way more
than you know just just grid searching
some hyper parameters trade-offs must be
evaluated and light of constraints
that's fairly obvious another thing for
many tasks you Python can perform nearly
as fast as lower level languages but you
guys probably already know that we were
you know talking about siphon and numba
with the just-in-time compilation before
you know and just in the interest of not
over complicating things and writing
code that you would want to maintain
yourself you know use use Python where
you can if that's what you know the data
science team is using hopefully I've
convinced you guys that this water for
commerce pond is a win-win scenario you
know show me where you can get six point
two five percent in 40 days and you know
maybe i'll i'll give you some my money
to a little bit later but a real big
opportunity for investors but more
importantly it's it's really an
opportunity for suppliers i started off
talking about c2fo s mission to champion
suppliers and to solve that global
conundrum of 32 trillion dollars just
being locked up in accounts payable and
accounts receivable right think about if
we were able to repurpose that 32
trillion think about the trickle-down
effects for the global economy and last
but not least creating great solutions
with open source is part of open source
too so oftentimes you know you just
think about the the development side of
things but a lot of these projects a lot
of these libraries wouldn't have the
trajectory wouldn't have the momentum
unless there were people using them
building great things on the other end
so just some things to keep in mind
hopefully i have some time for questions
here
okay yeah I'll be here for a few minutes
if anybody has any questions or you can
tweet at me